the confusion continues and so too does
the rapid change of leadership
Wanda Vasquez being sworn in as Puerto
Rico's new governor she had previously
said she didn't even want the job but as
justice minister she's next in line of
succession and was obligated to take it
I saw my car gonna go in the water I'm
taking this job as your governor at this
historic moment without ever having any
political aspirations but now with the
firm desire to complete my mission
to serve the people in the best way I
can she replaces Pedro Pierluisi who
took office on Friday he served as
governor for just five days before the
Supreme Court ruled his swearing-in
unconstitutional because he wasn't
confirmed by the Senate massive street
protests forced Pierre Louis's
predecessor Ricardo Rocio to resign amid
a scandal involving his bolger text
messages and allegations of corruption
so it's the third governor in six days
was sworn in it was clear many Puerto
Ricans still are not happy what do you
think of the new governor Wanda Vasquez
I think it is a bad person when she was
the Secretary of Justice a lot of people
die they don't have the resources and a
lot of resources got lost so she didn't
do anything and I'm concerned about she
getting the position because she's part
of the Ricky Rozay administration and
the corruption it will be on the
Fortaleza in in all of Puerto Rico I
mean she don't shine don't change
anything that is a sentiment felt by
many here some say they will not settle
for this new governor no I'm gonna stay
on the three protesting because I think
it's my duty I think it's my duty and if
I want change I have to be part of it
Puerto Rico is an island of 3 million
people and a territory of the United
States it's going through its worst
financial crisis ever and it's still
trying to recover from a devastating
hurricane two years ago that left much
of the island without power
for many months the political
uncertainty now is not making matters
any better the people will have to wait
a while longer to pick their own
governor elections aren't scheduled
until November next year
Gabriel Sandow al Jazeera San Juan
Puerto Rico